i'm going to play a video for you today
that i know many of you will think has
to be fake it has to be a comedy skit it
has to be satire it must be from
saturday night live and it's not
i'm going to play a clip for you today
of a mom interviewed on fox news who is
suing
suing her son's school
because her son will no longer do chores
at home because he's been taught
critical race theory apparently her son
is half black she says in a new york
post article that her son looks um
hawaiian
and she says all of a sudden because of
critical stuff that her son has been
taught
he won't do chores around the house
anymore i it is
unbelievable look at this all right so
melissa your your son is uh the father's
black you're white and
he'd never mentioned issues with race
before you're saying what exactly
changed
right we didn't have issues before he's
in eighth grade they introduced this
critical
program and they introduced the critical
program and all of a sudden what
happened listen to this and now he's
having racial issues that was not there
before what kind of racial issues is he
having
well he's seen himself just as a black
man he's seen things that don't go his
way as racism
and he's finding safety in numbers now
so he's finding safety in numbers i
would love to explore that more you're
saying
he gets a bad grade at school he blames
racism or
a girl rejects him on a date racism are
those the kind of things you're seeing
yes i ask him to clean the house racism
yeah
you're kidding right are you serious
no i'm serious they have totally changed
his perspective
can you imagine
hey um you you're supposed to vacuum
that's racist mom hey i'm your mom it's
time to vacuum i mean it's you're suing
the school
because it's i i can't get
how is this a real segment it's very
difficult to believe that this isn't a
plan
i actually thought
this is going to be another one you know
when these people prank fox news and it
turns out that it's actually a complete
and total joke like there was this
famous one we interviewed the guy max
rice who went on fox and he pretended
that he was a former obama voter who
didn't who wanted to vote for romney
instead because of some he lost a bet it
was like this whole fake thing and later
it came out it was all a joke
i wrongly assumed this was going to be a
joke and the the there's one other part
one possibility is the mom has
completely lost control of just
parenting like she just doesn't know how
to parent that's one possibility the
other possibility is that this is sort
of like made up or exaggerated
and she's using her kid as a political
pawn like at some point don't you say
listen you've you've just got to do your
homework you've just got to do your
chores i'm i'm the parent i'm in charge
here and she goes on an international
news outlet which i can't imagine is
going to make circumstances that much
better for her kid in school as well
that it just strikes me that that's not
going to be a particularly useful thing
and then again in this new york post
article that was written about this you
know new york post it's not a source we
typically use but that's where she was
she was interviewed
virginia's school virginia schools
anti-racist program has changed my son
mom says
and she did say he looks hawaiian
he's beautiful
he didn't used to see himself as
different from other kids sure his skin
tone was a little darker his dad is
black and right i guess the mom is white
and native american but she never wanted
to box him in with stifling racial
classifications and now an anti-racist
curriculum
she says is itself racist because it
indoctrinates students and teachers in a
racial
essentialist worldview
this is really wacky stuff if it wasn't
so sad and dangerous
and disheartening it would be funny
because it seems like comedy but it's
not and i would expect a lot more of
this over the next few years
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video